HEALTH.
THEY SAY HE’S NEAR DEATH.
JOINING ME TO TALK ABOUT THAT AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS
SHENANIGANS IS COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT, KELLYANNE CONWAY.
FIRST THINGS FIRST.
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE HEARING
ABOUT KIM JONG-UN?
AND HAS THE PRESIDENT REACHED
OUT TO ANYONE?
>> I WILL NOT COMMENT ON THAT.
THE PRESIDENT WILL MAKE ANY
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT A HEAD OF
STATE.
ALL OF US WILL GET OUR CREDIBLE
INFORMATION OFF LINE, NOT ON
LINE.
THE OFFER THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
MADE TO NORTH KOREA STANDS.
THERE CAN BE GREAT ECONOMIC
LIBERTY FOR THE PEOPLE OF NORTH
KOREA.
BUT THERE WILL HAVE TO BE SO
MANY CONDITIONS MET FIRST.
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH WHICH IS
THE VERIFIABLE COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
SLA.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN FIRM ON
THAT AS HE TRIED TO BROKER A
DEAL IN THAT WAY.
AS TO THE HEALTH CONDITION OF A
FOREIGN LEADER.
I WILL LEAVE THAT TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL OR THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT ON THAT.
JUDGE JEANINE: I AM GOING TO ASK
YOU ABOUT SOMETHING THAT HAS
JUST COME OUT THIS EVENING IN
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
THAT’S THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
PLANNING ON REPLACING ALEX AZAR.
THAT’S MORE THAN JUST ONLINE.
IT’S IN THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
SOMEWHAT I WOULD SAY TO THAT IS
SECRETARY AZAR HAS SERVED FOR
OVER TWO YEARS.
WAS IN THE WITH SITUATION ROOM
YESTERDAY AND WAS THERE MOST OF
THE WEEK.
AND IS A BIG PART OF THAT.
HE OVERSEES A HUGE BINLT.
THE CDC, FDA, THEY ARE ALL
CONNECTED AND REPORTING TO THE
HHS SECRETARY AT SOME LEVEL.
WHAT I FIND CURIOUS AND
DISAPPOINTING, HE TIME I READ A
STORY ABOUT THE PERSONNEL
CHANGE.
THESE DAYS IT HAS TO DO WITH
SOMEBODY WHO HAS OVERSIGHT OVER
THE PANDEMIC.
YOU HAVE SOME PEOPLE WISHING OR
WILLING THAT WHERE FAUCI WILL BE
FIRED OR DR. BIRX WILL QUIT AND
THEY WILL NO LONGER BE AROUND.
AND THE SECRETARY OF THE HHS
WILL BE REPLACED IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PRESIDENT DEALING WITH A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU ARE
COMING FROM AND WHERE YOU ARE
GOING.
LET’S PIVOT ON JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN APPARENTLY SAID
THAT -- I THINK THE EXACT QUOTE
IS SOMETHING LIKE HE’S NOT HAPPY
WITH THE $2 TRILLION AND HE
WANTS A HELL OF A LOT MORE,
THAT’S A QUOTE.
AND HE SAID THAT TODAY.
IS THIS ALL ABOUT PRINTING MORE
MONEY?
IS THE MAN FOCUSED?
DOES HE KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> HE DOES IN THIS WAY.
HE’S TRYING TO COULD YOU TO -- T
ORANGE WTOW TO THE LEFT.
HE’S SOUNDING LIKE THE FAR LEFT
CANDIDATES HE BEAT IN THE
PRIMARY.
NOW HE’S TRYING TO SOUNDS LIKE
THEM.
BUT HE’S REALLY BEING -- GIVING
INTO THE CRAVEN ELEMENTS OF HIS
PARTY FOR WHICH THERE IS NEVER
ENOUGH MONEY.
WHAT I FOUND CURIOUS AND
REGRETTABLE ABOUT JOE BIDEN’S
INTERVIEW, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE THINGS HE WANTS TO INVEST IN
AND THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS AND MAKING SURE
WE HAVE THE VACCINE AND
THERAPEUTICS.
THE FACT THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
HOT SPOT SOMEWHERE.
AS WE START TO RE-OPEN PIECES OF
THE ECONOMY WITH IT’S
APPROPRIATE.
THAT’S WHAT JOE BIDEN SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON.
BUT HE WAS CURSING IN THE
INTERVIEW.
HE HAD ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT.
BUT HE DIDN’T OFFER ANY
SOLUTIONS.
WHAT HE OFFERED WAS THE TYPICAL
GRAB BAG OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THERE WAS A REPORTER A FEW
MONTHS AGO THAT SUGGESTED HOUSE
HOLDS WOULD BE $50,000 TO
$70,000 PER HOUSE HOLD IF WE PUT
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IN EFFECT.
THEY WERE ALL COW TO WERE ALL KO
BUT WHEN SHE SAID WE NEED THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
REMEMBER THIS ONE?
HOW MANY VOTES DID IT GET?
ZERO.
NOW YOU HAVE GOT JOE BIDEN
RUNNING ON THIS PLATFORM.
SO IT MAKES NO SENSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING SURE
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES,
INDIVIDUALS IN NEED ARE GETTING
THAT MONEY THROUGH THE CARES
ACT.
$75 BILLION MORE FOR HOSPITALS.
RESEARCH, INCLUDING VACCINES,
AND $300 BILLION PLUS MORE FOR
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
JUDGE JEANINE: KELLYANNE, VERY
QUICKLY.
THIS WHOLE IDEA OF AND THE
LATEST THING TO COME OUT ON
LARRY KING, THE MOTHER OF TARA
REID.
SHE IS CALLING IN TO LARRY KING
TALKING ABOUT HER DAUGHTER
HAVING A PROBLEM WITH JOE BIDEN.
HOW CAN DEMOCRATS LOOK AT
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY ARE SO
CRITICAL OF REPUBLICANS AND THEY
HAVE THE GUY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT WHO IS BEING ACCUSED
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IF NOT
WORSE.
>> TWO THINGS GOING ON HERE.
THE WHOLE #metoo MOVEMENT, THE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVED THIS PERSON
OR THAT PERSON WITH THIN OR NO
EVIDENCE BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLITICAL LEANING AND BECAUSE OF
WHO THEY WERE TRYING TO STOP
FROM THE SUPREME COURT OR THE
PRESIDENCY.
THEY ARE NOT ON SOLID GROUND
HERE.
THEY ARE BEING DISINGENUOUS AND
HYPOCRITICAL.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
TRYING TO PUSH JOE BIDEN OUT OF
THE RACE.
THEY ARE USING THIS AS A
BACK-DOOR EXCUSE TO CALL INTO
QUESTION, CAN WE AFFORD THIS
KIND OF SCANDAL LEADING INTO THE
ELECTIONS.
BIDEN IN HIDING THE LAST FEW
WEEKS HAS HELPED HIM.